we've got a big announcement for you
guys but before we give you that we just
wanted to take a moment to say
thank you so much to every single one of
you who's been supporting the show
whether that's on patreon subscribe
start paypal whether you remember on
youtube whether you've sent a one-off
donation whether you've sent us cash in
the post because you didn't want us to
know who you are
whoever you are wherever you are thank
you so much
but the big announcement is that we are
going to be launching on locals
which is a very special platform that is
different to all those other ones we've
just talked about
the incredible thing about locals is
that it gives
a community feel to the platform which
means it's a place for
people like you if you want to come and
talk with like-minded people
because let's be honest if you listen to
trigonometry not everybody likes it
there might be a time where you don't
feel comfortable saying certain things
like
maybe everyone who voted for trump isn't
a flesh-eating pedo zombie
hashtag pedo lives matter now the real
serious point here is that
locals is completely different to
patreon subscribes to
and paypal with those it's essentially
you're giving us money you might get
something in exchange
but on locals what you get is being part
of a community you can post your own
memes you can comment on the
latest episodes you can have
conversations about the topics that we
raise
you can even talk about why francis
looks like a mole absolutely it
is a social media platform all we've
done is eliminate the [ __ ]
exactly and well we're gonna have to let
me go then
but but anyway uh the point is it's very
very different to everything else
and if you give us the amounts that you
give us on patreon
subscribe stay on paypal for example if
you give us 25
a month you still get a month if you
give us 50 a month you still get to do a
monthly
zoom call with us if you give us over
200 a month which some of you top dogs
do
uh then you get a one-on-one call or
meeting with us whenever
this lockdown is lifted in 2028 so see
you then
when we will all be gray head slightly
fatter but still is problematic